one piece takes place in a fictional
world not too dissimilar to our own
though much of the planet's surface is
covered by water the only continent is
called the Red Line a narrow strip of
land that goes all the way around the
globe also circling the globe is the
grand line a stretch of ocean that's
known for its rapidly changing weather
and dangerous sea life when they cross
these two lines split a huge body of
water known as the blue sea into four
quadrants there are many many islands in
the blue sea some of them safer than
others this is a world full of pirates
after all the story follows a straw hat
pirate named after the hatw by their
optimistic Captain Monkey D Luffy it's
Luffy's dream to find the legendary
treasure known as the one piece which
was hidden by the famed pirate Goldie
Roger before his execution at the hands
of the world government whoever finds it
will be proclaim the new pirate king and
Luffy won't stop until that title is his
he knows he can't do this alone however
so he sets about putting a crew together
and making a name for himself